okay I would like to say massive
achievement for 2023 of getting Conor to
put a [__] Final Fantasy game we have
we into jrpgs we did it guys uh yeah
Final Fantasy I honestly the series here
I'll put but I just put seven you play
seven yeah I played seven and eight
which did you prefer seven seven yeah
the visuals have not done that well
though admittedly admittedly I played it
with some mods that upscaled the
backgrounds right and some other things
I'm telling you man I I know some people
are like it's a bation to play it with
mods but some of these mods are so
[__] good I played the 60 FPS mod
which is amazing on PC um and I played
it with uh speed up as well uh yeah and
also there was a widescreen mod you have
to just expand the backgrounds
especially if like you're in an area
where all the background is already like
rendered in it would just fill out the
screen which just makes it a little
easier to to I mean looks looks nicer
all the mods I used I really really
really felt were very faithful um and
cuz I I what I did is when I was putting
all these mods on I was like looking
between I kept starting the game with
and without mods to see if it was like
too Gody or too ugly with the mods but
all of them I really really thought made
it look really nice okay I need to know
now your opinion on this now that you've
played Seven all right [__] Mary Hill
yui aith or Tifa
uh I'm going to let you know right now
there is no correct answer I I will in
your opinion [__] youthi B kill aith and
marry Tifa
Bas okay what
okay all right so that's the cannon
answer right yeah that is that is the
correct answer actually uh yeah I mean I
feel like it's I mean I I I was really
happy that I somehow went 26 27 years uh
it might be 27 years by the time this is
out I don't know when this um
without [__] knowing anything about
this game I I I knew zov bad and that's
about it that's all I knew yeah yeah um
which almost didn't know you didn't know
big spoiler I didn't I actually didn't I
know some someone dies but I didn't know
who or when right okay uh so that must
have hit you when it happened I was kind
of shocked cuz I was like wait I we
could have revived everyone
else standing there like Phoenix down
Phoenix down I really really enjoyed it
uh it was kind of fun cuz I felt that
throughout the 30 odd hours 36 hours I
was playing it there was never a point
where I felt like I had to grind which
is again one of my big pluses for an RPG
did you have turbo mode on uh there was
turbo mode that I used for some battles
like Random Encounters when I trying to
try to get through a place yeah yeah uh
but throughout most of it I had it off
it was just when I was traversing or
going around a place yeah um but I yeah
I read every piece of dialogue I didn't
skip any cutes uh it was very fun I
really enjoyed the story I think one one
praise that I can give it uh that I feel
that I've played other games that don't
other RPGs that don't do this you have
to bear in Mind by the way I was want to
Peete about this my my first RPG that I
ever beat right was [__] blue dragon
on the Xbox 360 oh yeah I remember you
telling me this yeah so my exposure to
RPGs was dog [__] so I thought they were
all like that cuz you know that was from
uh I forgot his name the guy who made
founded or Square Enix sorry uh Square
soft and then left to make uh Mist
Walker something like that and then he
made Lost Odyssey which was very highly
acclaimed the first one he made was blue
dragon with collaboration with uh T Tor
Armor's to company and so this is this
supposed to be like one of the goat
games and it was just whatever it was
such a [__] game I'm just going to say
it was [__] and even like 15year old me
could tell visually it was fine but the
battle system was clunky and it was
boring last too long the one thing that
was amazing about Final Fantasy 7 that I
really appreciated it is it always felt
like the story was moving even when it
was like bombarding me with convoluted
story and dialogue I never felt like I
wasn't progressing yeah uh and I never
felt like I'd hit a wall of like this is
dumb why am I doing this you never felt
checked out of the story right no no and
the the material system which is like
their their system of managing magic I
guess or whatever was really [__]
good I really enjoyed it it was just a
great game what a [__] fun game it's
a great game think it's age well
absolutely I think the how' you think
the story went uh it was a little
convoluted at times right but that seems
part of the course for jrpgs and
Japanese media in general I think I
think the story is the thing that has
aged the the finest in 7 um the thing
that I didn't like about it is that and
this is more so I don't know how much
this is maybe squaresoft trying to cash
in because they've made so much media
adjacent to the Final Fantasy 7 Universe
it was very [__] annoying having
everyone be like play this game watch
advent children do this do this play
uhis play crisis call do this and it's
like shut up shut up let me play the
[__] game let me play the game are
you going to play the remakes I I'm
going to wait till all three are out
yeah second one's coming out next year I
know I'm starting I'm starting my I'm
restarting my journey on the remakes I'm
have you played the original I haven't
no you should play the original you
should play the original the original
[__] loser play the original kind of
feel like I'd rather play the remakes
now that they're coming out I don't know
I really enjoy well they're apparently
going to change some of the story in the
remakes right yeah if they do I'll go
back I'm I'm kind of enjoying it like
going through it as it is kind of like
coming out now um the next one you go to
play Conor is 10 well I'm gonna I want
to play nine and 10 nine is all nine
what n this is so this is this is the
thing I hate about Final Fantasy when I
talk about it depending on who I ask I I
get like completely different opinion
someone will be like six is is the best
thing of all time is some be like okay
see what I mean and then they be like I
10's ey but Nine's really where it's at
nine has like nine I don't know anyone
who's talks about nine nine has like a
cult fan base like people who have
played nine like [__] love nine I've
played it's a good Final Fantasy but I
think if you want like the kind of Next
Generation Final Fantasy game to
experience like 10 is like the solid one
one thing that I when I was playing this
that I was kind of sitting there
realizing uh cuz this game came out in
1990 s eight uh which is one year after
Mario 64 came out and that was
revolutionary when that came out I was
thinking like I'm this is never going to
happen again where you play a game like
this that just absolutely blows your
mind and redefines everything oh yeah it
was this game and Ocarina of Time that
were the ones that were just like this
is the future of gaming and it's like
playing it I was like I would like I I
could understand I was like if I was the
hype if I was between like the ages of
14 and like 30 when this game came out
yeah I'd probably make my whole
personality about this game I probably I
would probably Define my entire life on
this game that's why six constantly gets
shafted because there the this would
literally blow my [__] mind if this
and it still did in some respect I'll be
honest yeah um it was really impressive
I really enjoyed it um I I yeah I I like
it is it the best jrpg you've played
thus far uh
jrpg yeah yeah i' say
i' say I think you know the problem is
Final Fantasy fans are annoying as [__]
I'll say it they suck they they they are
obnoxious and this happens whenever a
fan base knows their game is goated they
just become entitled and they know their
game is [__] a banger it's like the
Zelda fans who constantly prays time one
piece fans Now isn't it yeah and the one
piece fans becoming it and it's like hey
we get it but and I understand the the
visuals are a huge barrier and it's and
it's it's okay to say that the polygons
look [__] weird egg be looking ass
they have the [__] chunky arms and
and no [__]
biceps but the story is a banger yeah um
all right and uh absolutely amazing yeah
but would you would you recommend just
playing this or playing or waiting for
the remakes I I do recommend playing the
original cuz obviously people can be
like oh watch the original read the
Manga all that [__] I was like I only
get to experience this story for the
first time once you what I mean and I'm
like if you've already started playing
the Remake I think you should just see
the Remake till the end and then if
you're interested in it play the
original I don't think it's maybe it'll
be like an AA situation where oh the
rebuilds are like such a different thing
that builds on the original and then
maybe I'll play the original but I mean
as someone who started playing the
remakes after playing the original
countless times as a kid like I'm still
really enjoying the remakes I I think
one thing that will not be repli in my
opinion that I I haven't seen the the
new game [__] but one thing that I just
don't think that they'll be able to
replicate to the same extent there's no
shot they can make the music hit as hard
in the remake the music was so f i I
don't give a [__] about music the
[__] music in this game was so good
oh dude like every Final Fantasy game is
some of the best like game music like
Square does not miss when it comes to
music why did the music go so [__]
hard in every every section of this game
because ridiculous the music section of
square softer just full of goats that's
why like even if they just remake the
[__] trucks but I feel like the
PlayStation cuz they were so limited
back then by the hardware that the the
the unique sound of the PlayStation back
then was so [__] fun and nice and
epic and I just agree with you I I can't
even though you can probably get like
these giant orchestras you get this full
you know [__] dot wav [__] 48,000
khz quality perfect you know it's like
but there's something that was so good
about hearing the PE like the
PlayStation sounds so [__] so this
day when you hear the original
One-Winged Angel that was that yeah it
is absolutely [__] insane I I want to
go watch the Final Fantasy concert the
for seven concert I want to go watch it
now cuz that was [__] fire because I
remember playing the latest Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy 16 right and you
know there were some like epic moments
obviously it has great music I don't
remember a single track from it the top
of my head and I'm like I I remember
being I remember being some of the in
some of the boss battles being like oh
this feels epic but all I can remember
about the music is just it match visuals
EP epic Orchestra track that's all I
remember and I was like I can't really
remember anything else about the music
although I am hype for them to remake
the kns of the Round Table uh summon oh
yeah that was so [__] ridiculous when
I booted that up and I was like what the
[__] is this this this's this summon
animation that's like an hour like an
hour long for one attack it's so
ridiculous right um so I'm excited it's
like a whole film it's so ridiculous um
but yeah that great game very very
excited for it um fear and anger yeah
man I mean this kicked off we know we
know about this one about it but it was
so good it came out in 2018 but
obviously I discovered it this year uh
and my God what a [__] game what a
game I still think in terms of RPG I
still enjoyed this and I was more
encapsulated by the world than even
Final Fantasy 7 I was I was [__]
hooked it was so dark so gritting and
the game playay even though it was
[__] RPG
Maker was so [__] compelling that it
got me to be like hold on now let me
figure out what's going on in this world
why is it so [__] up yeah because I
was just so enthralled in it and I
really really really want you boys to
play it uh please do because it's so
[__] amazing and if you haven't
played it uh I'd recommend playing it go
check it out yeah it's it's so goed it's
so good and risk of rain 2 which I see
you play quite a lot I I've played a lot
this year didn't come out talk about
this I didn't really talk about it on
the podcast no
um did you know anything about risk R 2
I don't know anything RIS played RIS 2
yeah yeah yeah what when uh played it a
while ago uh alone no I had a I had a
friend play with um was addicting it's
so [__] addicting of these kind of
games don't really appeal to me but I
remember we played for like 3 hours or
something just trying to grind it out uh
basically you have uh every you spawn
into like a level and there's a
teleporter and you can go to the
teleporter at any point and fight the
boss if you click on the teleporter you
have to stay in the zone and a big boss
will spawn you kill the boss you get to
go to the next level now around the area
are powerups right so you need to get
the power ups and then go to the boss
and kill him however uh there's there's
one drawback and it's that the longer
you are taking it in general the harder
the game gets right so the more enemies
spawn the longer you the more enemies
spawn the more Health they have the more
damage they do and so it'll go from like
easy
normal hard very hard extreme death ha
lau and then like it just gets to the
point where the game is so [__] hard
that you can't you can't beat it so you
need to you need to get to the final
stage and beat the boss the final boss
before you kind of get too weak so you
have to kind of balance between like do
I just [__] go for it without the
powerups or do I risk it being more
difficult with power offs right yeah and
it's just a very it's a very and there's
tons of classes tons of characters it's
very Style ized um it's very arcade
likee feeling um and I played it a lot
with mouse and Pete and we just had such
a [__] good time and I put so many
hours into this game and I had so much
fun um and it really kind of captured
that energy of when I first played cod
zombies as like a teenager that kind of
like oh [__] this is just fun doing the
exact same thing over and over again um
the gameplay was so tight it was just a
really [__] fun game it's it's a it's
a great game to play with friends
because I played this at a gaming bar
and I was like what the [__] is this
yeah yeah I played this at the gaming
bar and we just had like a bunch of
people together and I'm like oh I'm
[__] addicted because with it it's
the last time I remember feeling that
kind of like couch gaming where all your
mates are just together trying to like
achieve something together and it was
just really really
addicting yeah yeah exactly exactly it's
really fun yeah every kind of play style
you know there's accommodating that's
also fun cuz only one person can get one
power up m so if you pick it up and you
should have given it to your teammate it
just leads to arguments and fun banter
you're like I'm going to take it you're
like no [__] you I should have gotten
that one that would help me um and
there's just so much like uh wild kind
of combinations of stuff you can add
where it gets ridiculous um your
powerups can be scaled infinitely and
get crazy CU you can get 99 of a power
up uh and it'll it'll scale it 99 times
and so it can get like real [__]
crazy right um it's just a really
[__] good game